we have a very backwards country in many
ways
a lot of you know that um we've seen
that during the last seven eight months
of the global pandemic we have a
pandemic
and donald trump supporters and right
wingers go after
the doctor telling us how to fight the
pandemic dr anthony fauci
needing full-time armed security anthony
fauci's daughters
needing security well now cbs has had to
fire a higher
rather full-time security for 60 minutes
correspondent leslie stahl
because trumpists are threatening her
life because
she asked questions of donald trump
during the 60 minutes interview that
aired on sunday night
an unidentified suspect called leslie
stahl's home on thursday
threatened her family said something
about neo-nazis this is a 78-year-old
reporter
who did her job trying to keep the
president accountable as we should have
the press doing in any
viable democracy and she now needs
security guards at her house
the trumpists instead of seeing their
dear leader
crumble under basic questioning and
saying wow maybe i shouldn't support
trump
they instead go after the interviewer
and she now needs security at her house
whenever she goes out in public because
trump supporters
are furious that she did an interview
that wasn't
gushing praise like what sean hannity
and maria bartoromo and rush limbaugh
and others do
is this what it means to win to be so
triggered
that you have to threaten a nearly 80
year old woman for asking
questions of the president this is what
happens though
when the president spends more than a
full presidential term
attacking the media calling them fake
and phony
and the enemies of the people people
start going after reporters
the media of course are not infallible
the media must be held accountable
media get things wrong and they should
have to issue corrections when they do
but this has gone too far guys trump
rose to power
in this wave of nationalism and
anti-press and anti-free speech
sentiment and these are the results
they've baked the cake now they've got
to eat it and i hate to tell you
leslie stahl's interview wasn't even
particularly difficult they were simple
questions
mr president you said x defend it with
facts and trump's not able to do it
the fact that trump can't answer doesn't
mean that the interview was in any way
that much hardball
in other countries where elected
officials are frequently actually held
accountable by the press
that would not be considered a tough
interview just because trump won't stop
whining about it
doesn't mean it was actually tough it
just means trump can't handle it
now of course all right wing media
that is about law and order and free
spree
free speech and a free press i'm sure
right wing media is denouncing these
threats against leslie stahl right
well i searched i couldn't find anyone
saying a word about it in right-wing
media
don't know why i wonder we need change
we need change we have to remove this
guy or things are going to get even
uglier there's no question whatsoever
and unfortunately in his removal things
may briefly get uglier
i i've been talking about that for a
while i am worried
about what trumpists may be capable of
if their dear leader is soundly defeated
six days from now but it has to happen
and understand that the reason we're not
going to hear criticism
of leslie stahl getting death threats
from the right and from trumpists
is the same that we have people
following
these evangelical scammers and making
them multi-millionaires
it will only end when we break the cult
of personality
the michigan governor had a kidnapping
plot against her
thanks to donald trump directing his ire
against her
and trump couldn't even flatly denounce
the people who planned the kidnapping of
gretchen whitmer
and meanwhile just a final note on the
60 minutes interview
republicans and trumpists have been
slamming cbs
because they didn't air the full
interview which 60 minutes never does
the way 60 60 minutes is a news magazine
they don't air uncut interviews they
record an interview
and they cut it to tell a story along
with images and whatever else
the reality is trump looked better
because 60 minutes couldn't air trump's
entire interview
the full interview which trump released
on facebook i think it was or maybe
youtube
it makes him look worse he said even
crazier things that
cbs cut out in the 60 minutes interview
they didn't just edit the interview
so that it would fit on tv in the
allowed time
they edited it because trump was making
lunatic unverified claims and not
answering questions
60 minutes helped trump by editing down
the interview
what a backwards world we're living in
right now we're going to have more on
this
on the david pakman show instagram page
david pakman show you can also find me
on instagram
check out my latest tomato haul from my
urban garden
by following me on instagram at
david.pacman
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer
i'm required to give these products
contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical